[Music]
well your prayers have an answer it's
time now for final exam where we see
which news professionals have been
paying attention to the news we do that
by pitting them against one another in a
best-of-five news quiz shannon bream as
you well know has entrenched herself as
the master of final exams last week she
completed a full Brady Bunch beating
Chris Starr wall to run her record to
nine and Oh tonight she goes for her
tenth straight win against America's
News headquarters host Leland Vitter a
man famous for his news acuity and hair
yeah and here general good temper and
good luck to you Leland well I have been
studying tape of you yeah you know I
realize you rigged Ducey's button so it
wouldn't work with Jillian iosys Leland
so I'm gonna cut you off there and tell
you the rules what you already know
since you watch the game tape hands on
buzzers I ask the questions the first
one to buzz in gets to answer that
question after wait till I finish right
asking it in order to answer every
correct answer is worth the point if you
get it wrong you lose a point best of
five wins are you ready yep game on a
first was a multiple-choice question
Democrats are urging Oprah to run for
president Donald Trump was asked about
this his response was it a she's no
stable genius she Oh stick to TV be
Oprah is a total tremendous loser sad
exclamation point or is it see I like
Oprah I don't think she's gonna run we
win fettered cc2 the tape a lot of fun
I like Oprah I don't think she's gonna
run you join a long list of people who
began yeah congratulations
question two another multiple choice the
question the president just unveiled his
latest nickname this time for Senator
Dianne Feinstein of California
what was that nickname was it a sleepy
Diane be sneaky Diane see swampy Diane
Wheelan bitter I'm going with
sneaky-sneaky diet not swampy sneaky not
sleepy roll tape
we do have this tweet last hour what was
it 20 minutes ago president the fact
that sneaky Diane Feinstein sneaky Diane
fine see here we go look at sloppy Steve
sneaky Diane Feinstein he's trying to lo
me Wow okay this is without precedent
but she is trying to lo you I agree with
that question three ladies and gentlemen
and we got some more Diane Feinstein for
you okay she gave an unusual reason for
releasing that transcript of private
testimony on the Trump dossier without
consulting any of her peers including
the committee chairman what was her
excuse this is where Shannon asked for
hints what was Diane Feinstein's excuse
she did it unilaterally and asked the
ranking Republican she's did it and she
said but I did it cuz I was off that day
it's a medical issue that's our first
hint it's something you can catch on the
subway I'm up by 2 I see from your child
Whelan fitter I'm just yes here based on
the hints a cold a cold cold flu some
type of cold is the answer and we will
see if the tape ratifies it I've cut it
I don't make it excused but I've had a
bad cold and maybe that slowed down my
mental facilities a little bit there you
go so close well yeah I mean about
narcolepsy okay next question against
the rules here it's best-of-five right
right but really incorrect answer puts
you in down a point okay so anything it
happens so dynamic yeah yeah and I
wouldn't count your points until their
final okay all right Thank You professor
another another multiple choice America
is still thawing out from intense
old weather one place in the United
States was colder than the surface of
the planet Mars
was it a in the state of Nebraska flat
and cold B in New Hampshire Mountain
isn't cold or sea the northernmost state
on the East Coast Maine Leland Feder I
shouldn't have done that based on the
rules but I'm going with New Hampshire
you're going with you Hampshire ham okay
New Hampshire is New Hampshire the
answer Mount Washington New Hampshire
it's so cold they were blowing bubbles
and they froze and you can see the guy
actually holding those bubbles as if it
was a baseball it feels like minus 100
tied for the second coldest place here
this is the benefit of working on the
weekends that Brian Dennis was doing
that live shot New Hampshire be colder
than Maine but you're right yeah it's
the tallest peak in New England Mount
Washington holy smokes
okay this is unprecedented but we're
still we still have a question to go you
ready I'm ready
okay be careful on this one an iconic
soda brand is making a desperate attempt
to appeal to Millennials young people by
unveiling new flavors ridiculous ones
like feisty cherry zesty blood orange
and twisted mango which brand is it
Shannon Breen thank cook I don't believe
you
it might be really Steve D blood orange
yeah is it diet coke diet coke is
getting a makeover you may notice some
slimmer cans there they are up on your
screen and Diet Coke is unveiling some
new flavors holy smokes this is a little
bit like when Winston Churchill retired
the post-war yes you may you can hand
this is the coveted Mallory they're mine
I'm crowding you mr. America well I am
gracious for for you and your tomorrow
the other note complete congratulations
to you Lila Nader shannon bream you've
been a fierce competitor terrifying
competitor looking forward to graduation
thank you nine in a row congratulations
I'm gonna retire now no no you go for
nine now pay attention to the news all
week every week and we back next
Thursday with another news quiz be right
back